I just found out we first met 22 years
ago at a small College in Boston
yoky was a student in robotics at the
time did an unbelievably great thesis in
robotics with a very famous person
brought Brooks then moved on got a
MacArthur Genius award something I can't
even spell it became a very world-famous
professor of computer science at
University of Washington then moved to
Silicon Valley and forget it Astro
teller who's on the series before and
myself founded Google X moved to one of
the early employees at nest sold nest to
Google then took some time off a guess
and returned to nest and is currently
the nest CEO welcome on the program yeah
thanks Sebastian it's great seeing you
yeah what an honor Thanks do you
remember 22 years ago tried to erase it
but yes yes do remember you walking in
the hallway at the small University in
Boston yes so you've had this very rare
Korea situation value of ollie and a
top-notch professor and then ditched all
of academia and became a topknot
executive here in Silicon Valley what
did you learn
have you asked that to yourself I like
to copy your answer actually but what
did I learn I think you know I think
when I was in academia you know the
places where I wanted to really excel
was something that changes the world
thirty years from now that was really
important and then you know I had this
itch that I couldn't quite scratch in
being a professor where you know I
wanted to affect people change and
improve lives of people sooner than
waiting that long so just coming to
Silicon Valley and having the ability to
do that I learned a ton from doing that
that's just a whole lot of different
skill sets
to do that hypothetically if you were to
go back to a professor position what
would be different Wow
what do you mean by that like would you
be different professor teach differently
would you educate students differently
what do you know I think everybody could
less you better go yeah and partly I got
older right so I kind of know
more about what they should be expecting
but yeah I would absolutely teach
students differently not just from the
coming from school to another school and
you know just getting in a research but
really how to apply things that they
learn in school and then put that back
into the whole education system so I
would teach it definitely differently
it's nice nice
you also almost became a professional
tennis player as that correct yeah a
long time ago that's even longer ago
than 25 years ago we didn't know each
other yeah see look back at the time are
you happy not to be able tennis player
thing not sure I think if I was 15 again
would I still try to become a
professional tennis player absolutely
yeah so I wouldn't change the course
because by thinking that I was going to
become a professional tennis player so I
really thought that was all I was going
to do all my life I didn't think of
anything else I thought going to college
it's not about school but about tennis
that's really what I thought so going
through it that intensely taught me
something skills that I still use to
date on everything else that I do so I
would not change anything
competitiveness you know mental
toughness you know all this get
recovering from injuries all those
things are so hard and in life like
whether we're professors or students or
you know execs in Silicon Valley we run
into kind of similar situations that
over and over that's true yeah that's
very true when you're very good at it I
would ask you a personal question if I
may
oh so you you you worked at nests and
oversaw and were involved in the
acquisition earnest to Google and then
at some point you didn't actually made a
public announcement you decided to leave
nest and go to Twitter and work with
Alex wrote a person is now working
constantly with me turns out okay and
then you had a an illness and and you
made a very public posting about this
actually and the really change your
trajectory afterwards can you talk about
this yeah so you know I don't usually
talk about my sort of a radical
life-threatening event as much so thanks
for bringing it up but um no it's no
it's actually it's something that really
changed me so this was about two years
ago you know I was going
long thinking you know just like
everybody else that I could do anything
my life will last for a long time and
then yeah I basically had an event where
I realized that that's not true it could
end much sooner than I thought and it
really changed me in terms of what I
focus on to even sort of internally
reflect on Who I am and also what I want
to do for the rest of my life moving
from that point onward it's really
humbling I think since then I'm it's
really less about me it's a lot about
society it's a lot about how it's like a
second chance now I've got second chance
there must be a reason that I'm here
that I want to give back as much as
possible and I think it's a really good
feeling that's great that's great I mean
I thanks for sharing this with us I lost
my sister to life-threatening disease
about a month ago so I feel a little bit
of it but I think we're very very
grateful evictions be here any moment
any day it's a really great yeah really
it must be the same way yes yeah um okay
now after I personal question and you
definitely talks we always have our
students ask questions and we have so
many amazing students I would say
there's very few people to whom I look
up as much as they look up to yoki often
not just being on one of the toughest
fighters I know I'm are the most like
bomb hearted people I know but also that
you've been a supersonic edenia a
superstar in a company and you're still
an approachable human being is just
really amazing you also I know you're
raising four children and so on and
you're doing amazing things for women in
computer science if you're going to ask
about data and so on so it's great to
have you here and of course one of the
most creative geniuses on the world I
should say absolutely having work with
you get for the mirror right here listen
to yourself over you know I always
invite people whose IQ is higher than me
by such a large margin but let me ask
questions from from the audience some of
them unless specific someone walk more
career focus industry focused because
you're so much at the the pulse of
what's happening in Silicon Valley
Morgan asked the question about home
automation which of course is the coop
nest business
do you see home automation having a role
enabling care for senior citizens or for
disabled people it's a good question ya
know so actually nest has a mission and
mission statement and I'm sure you'd a
CD does too and then one of the things
that so it's a nest mission is to create
a home that cares for people inside it
in a world around it that's a huge
recent reason that I'm back I'm really
wanting to care for people in some
capacity and then I thought about it and
said where is the good place that I can
care for people and you know we spend so
much time at home well maybe about half
of our lives Wow actually more than that
maybe two-thirds of our life but the
house that you're sleeping so but you
know quite a lot happens at home and you
know in order to care for people in the
right way what a great place to do you
know from nest angle so absolutely and O
age groups all different shapes and you
know of people live in the home I love
to you know my research also was in
neurotics where we try to build devices
for people with disabilities neural and
physical disabilities so I really hope
that we get to connect that really
nicely in the future
whether it's for the elderly or you know
younger people or people with disability
so absolutely as I raised a question
which I look at Silicon Valley as a
whole we invent all these great
technologies one part of the SIA TV kind
of seem to almost entirely neglect is
actually the aging population this is
because the magaz occur Brooks and Larry
page's are very young or like why don't
we I'm the situate opportunity to go
after technologies that keep you two
independent longer and work with their
degrading whatever physical and
cognitive and perceptual capabilities
yeah no I agree so I think I've thought
about this a lot I know yeah I think
they're I think couple of things I mean
this is oversimplifying and and there
are a whole lot more complexity to it
one as you said that innovators are too
young and then by the time we really
think of the right solution and pain
points for the older people we're too
old to do that right thing right so I
think there's one part to that
think it's way too scary ha ha please
get old really fast so that we can do
the intubation no but yeah so I think
you know I think that's definitely one
thing but the other part is the whole
economy of needing to make money right I
think that people who adopt to
technology really fast are not the
elderly so we tailor it to the place
where a Silicon Valley company can make
the most amount of money and turns out
that's not the elderly market and also
elderly specific technology doesn't sell
because as we get older we will never
admit that we're getting older right we
would never buy something that's tuned
for the elderly because we don't believe
it that's true yeah so so I think that's
another reason that you know I think we
I bet the way we enter the elderly
market in many ways is to not build
something very tailored for the elderly
but for everybody that works just turns
out to be really really helpful for the
elderly it's a great answer it's a great
answer
so valya asked a question about Miss
haha this is going to be a Udacity
specific question what does a company
like do data like nest looking for in a
candidate and she says or he or she I
know of people who say that companies
like these don't hire anyone below a GPA
of 3.5 for international students GPA is
our grade point average four is really
good 3.9 sucks I was like not quite as
good so what was the question again
so what what do you looking for in the
candidate but what excites you or a
candidate so in terms of the GPA I mean
three point five I don't even know where
that name number came from to be honest
I didn't have it I know you work on that
so apparently I passed the bar
are you a quiet you weren't hired huh
originally you were quiet come on all
right they hired me first okay keep that
clear the record is clear I was hired no
but so yeah so I think GPA is just like
a tiny fraction of everything else right
I mean I asked I never asked for those
questions about how well did you do in
school that's just a little part of it
sure the fact that you took some of the
right courses at Udacity or wherever it
might have been is important but now how
did you even what did you get out of it
it how are you applying it to yourself
to the work you do or to your life right
and your ability to really put that in
applications and work really hard and
then change the world I think all of
those things are far more important than
how you do in school good that's great
um from John again phone s.coups woozi
what is the biggest difficulty for
companies like nest that work in both
hardware and software and and how do you
guys approaches how to solve these
difficulties yeah oh that's a good
question so for those people who are
interested in robotics or autonomous
driving car you know there so next is
part of Google and Google has a lot of
amazing software and then just getting
into the hardware so I see a lot of that
people moving from Google to nestin and
their struggle in and finding out how to
do hardware so I think that's just I'm
also learning as well watching them come
to nest and struggling why hardware
software combination is hard think they
are things that takes longer from the
point that you think you conceived the
idea and then you built it to the point
that you can ship it is much longer for
hardware software combo product so I
think that's the part it's really hard
to visualize it until you do it once and
all this what we call it like a
regression right like you put software
and hardware together and then both
sides plan perfectly and then the first
day you merge it everything falls apart
and some of the other things not easily
yes so I think you know those regression
that that the magnitude of that
occurring is far more when it's not just
software here's an anonymous question
which are also half is what do you think
needs to be done to make the tech
culture and business more welcoming to
women now and in the future hmm yes I
you know of course this whole women
issue is very passionate for me just
trying to do it myself but one of the
things that at least I'm again this
might be generalizing again but one of
the things that women and girls when I
go and talk to high school students in
junior high
junior high school students is that
they're looking for already sort of a
mission or bigger picture there's like
they're looking for a place where they
feel like they can
touch a lot of people's life so when
you're learning math and science as as
they are it's it doesn't really connect
to why it has meanings why it could help
people so I think it as we do more and
more of that
so we make it into much more of an
applications more of a project-based
right so there are lots of schools that
are really trying to do in a
project-based school mode so that math
is not just math it's not dry but you
know even how you dasa d does it right
it's like autonomous driving car but you
actually also teach math along the way
right that's exactly how those things
should be taught and I think those
things would bring more and more women
to you think you should study at k12
even pre-k levels totally yeah are you
doing it at Udacity we have very much
project focused I mean we unfortunately
still have a predominant male student
body unfortunately there's nothing I can
do about that
we're in the company itself yeah almost
entirely balance between females and
males partially because we're a stronger
mission mission driven yeah but I would
love to I would really love to change
that ratio
I mean you does it is not a work with
female only scholarship organizations
and nonprofits if we hand out
scholarships to women only and now I'm
thinking that the the violent of online
is actually much more protective in some
sense and gives you more freedom than a
big classroom dominated by arrogant
males but it's it's a long way to go in
my opinion yeah I'm surely important
yeah any oh there might be so I've asked
recently within NASA and Google and an
ask some women and said why do you want
to have more women right and then they
said because they like the connection
they'd like to sit next to other women
who feel like they can relate to each
other so I think that's a huge part
right to get more women we have to start
with a little bit more women so I think
that that's really important for us
that's hard to do but maybe that's one
of the things you'd acity wise it might
be sorry I'm not here to give advice
right but anyway you are thinking like
maybe I wonder if for women if there's a
place where you can do it online but
some environment together three students
together and then they're all female you
know something like that could be really
interesting we have a Facebook group
women get together and so on but yeah I
mean I'm open for any advice on I love
to learn what if you have a very strong
presence in the Middle East as our
contribution to world peace I would love
to make a broad Udacity contribution to
inclusiveness in the workplace not just
the female also ethnicities and other
things at our table to be yea balanced
similar related question from a
gentleman named Roy and says I'm over 40
right you're a young young chicken
spring haha get this fried chicken
smooching you're the professor andrew is
coming is it too late to start a career
in robotics AI or machine learning gosh
40 is so young actually my dad is 82 and
he is starting a new company and in you
know I think it's never too late right
if your brain is excited to learn new
things go for it I think that's why it's
so worth living in so many ways that we
should just continue to learn and if
machine learning in AI is the thing
right now that's going to take off which
we all believe in our next decade or two
get the skills and make sure that we do
it I think that's super exciting on a
plane this is actually a really strong
push towards Udacity studios the word
for it but she's really helping our
company yeah oh right yes I mean also
not to be a tough nut roboticist and I
think you picked this neurobiology thing
which was very unique at the time when
you worked at u-dub and even today when
you talk about it and there's all these
kind of thoughts about robotics this is
good or bad for Humanity where your
position you're serving there's new
dialogue about artificial intelligence
taking our jobs and if you believe in
our masks enslaving us and turn into
chicken sandwiches yes I don't know I
mean I mean it's partly maybe because I
know so much of the detail you know how
hard is to even get there so maybe
that's why I'm not as worried about them
but at the same time I mean coming from
my angle of Robotics really what I'm
trying to build is a way to make human
life more enhanced right so even nest
product
why do we build a thermostat it's not
because it looks beautiful in the wall
and that was huge part of it but we made
it beautiful so that people buy it and
then they might forget about it but
turns out they can save energy
we're making people who they want to be
because everybody says I want to save
energy but turns out they're a little
bit lazy to really do it so we do it for
them we just made them a better person
right so in that very similar way as we
continue those technologies should be
contained to use this an assistive way
to make person if it was a people with
disabilities and that's where the field
that I started off you know they lost
something that they used to have whether
it's an arm or part of the brain and I'm
CEM AI machine learning robotics helped
them to get back to where they were or
who they want to be and then there's a
little bit of an enhancement bit right
like can they become a better musician
can they you know save energy some of
the things that we might not be able to
do naturally I would say my pocket
radius may be an enormous league of
eight musician this play was on there oh
yeah great as I asked related questions
why do some futurists say that robots
can never mimic humans when human
behavior is just a series of on and off
synapses in the brain like zero ones on
a computer oh gosh people ask really
hard questions yeah I mean theoretically
we should be on and off switches and we
should be able to mimic but there's so
much to learn I've studied brain science
for years and I've only gotten deeper I
haven't started coming back out saying
like I think we got it right it's so
complicated and I'm yeah anyway so I
think from that point of view
[Music]
one day theoretically it sounds like
it's possible I just can't see it yet I
you know in 2017 2018 2030 2100 from the
view of 2017 onward I think the level of
understanding of our brain is still just
like the scratch the surface a little
bit that really understanding like if we
simulated crazy amount of ones and zeros
switches should it somehow become a
human I don't so you'd say that
even though if you have this amazing
progress and deep learning and
and machine learning and we now have
examples for learning systems outperform
human go players or chess players or
lawyers or dermatologists it's still a
lot of far cry from actually becoming
more human-like yeah and I think life I
mean weird this incredibly unique
organism which happen to survive in this
crazy universe right so many different
accidental zeros and ones which became a
cockroach which is pretty good deal
actually or you know or just steps on
you they get flat and then they keep
going by yes that's right so I think you
know I think cockroach is a pretty good
deal and then actually for about the
most of those zeros and ones which might
have existed in this giant universe
probably got extinct because they didn't
quite get the ones in zeros right so I
think of all those billions and
trillions of all those different
iterations of cases to actually become
something human-like is really really a
you know a lucky little tiny little
sliver maybe we'll get there one day but
again I'm not quite there I will forever
remember this conversation that
cockroaches you go to you next time I
see a cockroach should be very
respectful awesome changing my
perspective on things
last question really asking question
about augmented reality and it's a
question with three different
technologies yes how do you see the
convergence of other technologies such
as augmented reality and mixed reality
benefiting the future of neural robotics
Oh interesting actually so new robotics
when I was doing research was about
having a robot whether it's wearable or
stationary to work with human to you
know to rehabilitate them or to get them
to do some function that they lost one
of the projects that I had I even spun a
incredibly unsuccessful company on was a
stroke rehabilitation at home so the
idea was that people who have stroke
there are a lot of people who have
stroke on the early basis and then about
2/3 of them survived and then those who
survived most of them end up with some
level physical disability but they're
all usually a little older and then they
don't get to go to rehabilitation all
the time because they're not able to
take themselves to the hospital so
they don't get the opportunity to
rehabilitation so what I thought would
be great is like haha they can do this
at home so I built a system which was
augmented reality like it known before
anybody else working there see that's
right it was way too early in time after
this with it you have a member yeah yeah
exactly so and then and then to then
have a robot that they're working with
and an arm maybe disabled and you can't
move very much and then they're playing
a game or some tasks specific you know
thing that they're working on and as
they're doing it because it's fun and
also we are fooling with them and I'm
just playing with their brain a little
bit in such a way that they start to
move more and more so and then the
therapists get the feedback then
everything is connected Wi-Fi to the
office sometimes it's real-time
sometimes it's just results so all of
that is going to become a reality
hopefully soon I think this is the time
is ripe so I mean uh now the technology
is pervasive and we fantastic gave some
of our students picked it up last thing
I I wanted to spring up we launched a
robotics nanodegree and you are a
world-class roboticist and next to being
a world-class product person and CTO
nest
any advice for students in robotics what
to do what to be excited about what what
to be aware of interesting so I think
one of the advice is that just because
you study robotics you don't have to
build a humanoid I think a lot of people
immediately imagine if I study robotics
I have to find those three companies
that are building a humanoid robot or
something that has a face in my mind
that the what you learn in a class is
immediately used for for so many
different companies I mean nest
constantly hires people who have
electromechanical you know background
with especially robotics control systems
background that's so useful but there
are so many companies now that this
Internet of Things and then so many of
the hardware software combination
companies are coming along so make sure
that robotics is not about just a small
thing but just you can really brag about
it and go out and then use it for so
many things unfortunately out of time
you're going to spin super super
insightful is great thanks for twenty
two years of French everything
he talks today is our tenth series can
see it for the 11th very soon and thank
you yeah thank you thank you I'm honored
so I've been told that I this is the
time to take audience questions and fire
them off yes I saw in a nest website
yeah this camera that can detect
strangers or people who's coming into
the house it's a crime detection thing
right and what's next position or or
your position into making this in into
like in a public space so more like
massive scale like a surveillance camera
here let me repeat the question right
okay very first name Jay so Jay from the
audience asked a question I observed the
nest now is able to find amazingly
accuracy individuals when you buy a nest
cam and understand whether the same
person's before and attract intruders so
the questions you ask is there going to
be a plan a nest to go forward into
we're public places and turn nest into
kind of a I hate to say this
surveillance company which is it sounds
negative but some company that gives
airports or shopping malls and awareness
of the interior yeah so I mean there
thanks for the question there so many
different angles to this but let me see
if I can cover some of them so one yes
we launched a really beautiful camera
which has the feature which detects what
we'd like to think is a familiar faces
detection so we know that when loved
ones come home and they're been
notification about you know Sebastian
just came home you know that's sort of
how the feature works but of course as a
by-product as you thought about it it
says a way if they're not part of the
family members then there might be
strangers absolutely and then you know
hopefully that's going to save some
people's homes in the future as well and
I think they'll be exciting and so I
think that's that but then the question
if would we want to go ending outside of
the house of course our core promise of
nest is to build create a home
that takes care people inside in a world
around it there's a world around it
though so you know but we really try to
focus around people's home as much as we
can
are we going to go outside we'll
probably consider it are we going to
really become the surveillance company I
don't know another question yes and
versi first name is Chris you guys
talked about no jobs right and all these
new technologies like self-driving cars
they're going to create a lot of jobs
but more like 10 to 15 years from now
but now while the process is happening
during the transition time the jobs are
going to be squashed right is it a
humane way of dealing with that and
that's one the second question is is
Silicon Valley really responsible for
that or is it government okay so Chris
Chris is asking a question that is based
on a hypothesis because you guys voice
to us which is self-driving cars and
these new technologies create jobs but
it's going to start playing drops 15
years from now and in-betweens will be a
trough that we lose jobs and his
questions were to yogi is there humane
way to deal with this and secondly some
are provocateurs to say is it sitting
values fault
are we responsible for this yoke's more
I'm so glad you answered
the whole weight of the valleys on top
so yeah again thanks for the questions I
mean these are really important things
that we all should be discussing moving
forward and this is really not a promo
for Udacity but the way I think about it
is that we're going to create new types
of job right that just currently doesn't
exist and if we look 10 15 years from
now as you said there's some new job
increase that's going to happen we have
to get those people ready right so the
the kind of education currently is
completely tailored for the current
society with no technology so what are
the next sets like the fact that you
know you offer this autonomous driving
car course I mean you are getting people
ready to create those but why not create
additional courses and then degrees
which prepares people to be able to work
in a totally different skill set what
we're trying to do this to be honest we
have in digital marketing and many other
fields that are digitally enabled techno
the work fields that we can bring
students new skills and yeah yeah I
think I mean why take would be the
change of pace is accelerating so it
changed the pace of change is
accelerating so things are moving fast
and fast ever before and we live longer
than ever before and that to me really
mandates that we a society are willing
to stare the kids over lifetime not just
once in a lifetime yeah crashing yeah
hey so you talked about you know serving
the elderly and their needs so a broader
question will be right now I feel the
money lies in problems which yeah Cedric
Arsenal is great but there are certain
problems which are not able to solve
because there's not much of money there
or glamour there so how do you feel we
can cater to that problem how do we make
brilliant minds focus on such problems
as men just like you're pointing to you
talk about as early as an example or
what is an example there are other
social problems which we have like like
poverty poverty good
if believe might focus on such problems
I think we can come up with a surrogate
what's your name Gish
garish so garish is question is an
excellent whatever you like this he
points out that a lot of money goes into
like first-class problems like making
your phone shiny or wherever it is and
he points out correctly that there's
many important problems like poverty or
maybe clean drinking water that don't
seem to attract the same amount of
energy because they seem to be less
financing and less payment available for
solving those problems so he's asking
yogi how can we get brilliant people
like herself
focus more on these kind of problems
great great question and actually again
the after my life-changing event I think
about this all the time so I think there
too again there might be many many ways
to do this there are two trends that I
see one is the foundation approach right
so Bill Gates when you said about the
water I thought about that and says you
know he said I got lucky and then build
a Microsoft and now I want to give a lot
of money to really this part which
doesn't get a lot of attention and those
folks are run by real business people
they're really brilliant people running
Gates Foundation right so I think it's
not that those people who are getting
paid very little as I gave foundation so
I think they're doing it pretty well you
know marks
berg of course started a foundation
related to science and you know just
really advancing that in a way that's
going to beg and hopefully benefit
people who don't usually benefit from
the Silicon Valley typical companies and
making the phone shiny so that's one
area and I also have a non-profit on the
side which I also got frustrated with
the fact that I could not build a
company that would make money to build
devices for people with disabilities
because it just I will not never make
money so this whole idea of the
nonprofit is to build things for people
utilizing the talent in where I'm at so
Silicon Valley here when I was a Seattle
I was building certainly no talents from
Seattle to build things for people and
then give them out for free right so I
think those are great things that we can
do that's number one the number two is
to have more and more mission driven way
of thinking about things right so
companies
I'm very mission driven I work for a
for-profit company but I really try to
ground ourselves as much as possible to
balance the revenue as well as the
mission correctly right I think those
things are really important and also
balance the thing right so that if we
all are thinking mission driven then
when we build things we make sure and
says you know what we're primarily
selling for the mass to make money but
we make sure that it works really
elderly it works for the poor right like
there are different ways of making sure
that we're covering as much of the
ground as possible and maybe we can even
have a system we can give those devices
for much less money we don't have to
make money off those Google has the org
which has a lot of good intention for
that so there are so many different ways
of hopefully doing it it's not enough
though it's absolutely not enough yet so
many such a question is right
well at places like mass or vamo they're
people with like 20 years experience in
computer vision
basic mental challenges and the other
hand like we like what past year have
only faced computer vision like last
year or next month so how are we going
to many only contribute to what they're
doing so here's a question from Sasha
you observed correctly that if you go to
establish tech companies like lame-o and
others that a lot of the engineers have
maybe a decade or more of experience in
something a computer vision and I assume
you're studying at Udacity something
related to computer vision so social
studies self-driving cars at Udacity and
as a result does deep learning and one
of the things but is worried if you end
us the work field his experience might
be half a year and total or a year in
total and how can he as a newcomer to
the field contribute to a field that has
so many seasoned veterans yeah so thanks
for the question
it's interesting I actually think that
myself as well as the company tries to
have this balanced as much as possible
so people who have 20 year experience is
expensive we don't really want to hire
those people only we want to make sure
that people we hire will get trained and
love the experience and will forever
stay at wherever I'm at to you know just
keep we can nurture them take them early
because they got huge talent that's
coming up right and then we can bring
them to become who we love to continue
to work with so I think all that process
is there I agree that there are a lot of
people I think historically to like way
mouths been around for about 10 years so
there are a lot of people who entered
with that maybe 1 to 5 year old of
computer vision experience now has long
experience but I'm not too worried about
that I think you know Udacity program
and on the level of experience Udacity I
hope but very carefully about exactly
the right kind of data the experience
and in the class sets that's needed to
be able to enter place like Google and
way mo and be valued yeah I want to add
my personal answer to this session I
actually have a bias against
veterans and against experts and
whenever starts something be it Udacity
or self-driving cars or whatever do I
don't hire experts I category this is
the self-driving car team Google started
with a single person without any
experience in the field of automotive
even though there's tens of thousands
qualified automotive engineers and the
reason is experts tend to be excess of
the past not the future and our
technologies change so rapidly that it's
a really good risk to get stuck in one
generation of technology and not being
able to move to the next one as an
individual so I almost had the opposite
hiring bias take self-driving cars when
I started the Google team the team deep
learning had not yet seen its prime date
and machine learning was an esoteric
discipline that no one believed in so we
build an architectures very geometric is
very much driven by as we understand the
XYZ coordinates of any obstacle and the
Delta of X Y Z to understand where it's
going and that's the core essentially of
of of that approach and then deep
learning came along of course I don't
know what they was doing today but I see
all the new companies right now starting
with the deep learning is the core
discipline and self-driving cars and
making an unbelievable progress more
than I could make back in the day with
geometric reasoning when you when you
hire veterans I would argue to anybody
really check whether they're open minded
and where they're willing to move on
understand that the paradigm is shifting
it's shifting in every discipline and
shifting in mint software engineering
where there was a snow Times article
yesterday about how to many students
cheaper copying code I think you should
copy code and self engineering today is
mostly a copy-paste or integrate into
API science when I grew up some sort of
engineering was right every single line
from scratch right and we did assembler
every type will give you a different
behavior would you be caught by your
compiler so so it's these distinct
change so fast I think if you're smart
about it as a newcomer you actually have
an advantage and these
that's my opinion and bring me a
footnote there's something if we don't
teach very valid Udacity yet which is
working in teams and building large
software systems that's probably where
experts have a bit of an advantage today
if you have experience in this and it's
on my list right now to enhance this and
Udacity some students like yourself come
out you have more of an experience in
being large scope for systems anyhow
with that I want to close you know I did
some of the talking again it's great
having you here thank you thank you
thanks for you answers
[Applause]
[Music]